alors mareva galanter vous êtes
amoureuse nous en sommes très heureux et
on va voir tout ce que vous seriez prête
à faire par amour
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
arrêter le cinéma
attention non parce que c'est pas
quelque chose qui ne demanderaient pas
bon non il est bien et bien ce mec là
bien est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à retourner vivre à tahiti
aujourd'hui non mais eux-mêmes petit
jeu j'aimerais être être grand-mère à
tahiti enfants dans le sud pour grand
mère grand-mère auteurs
[Musique]
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
vous êtes
ardisson il est
même carrément buisson
je fais déjà fait des jeunes non et non
mais dis donc chez nous ici les 6,3
moite à progresser
les bourguignons
mais j'ai beaucoup bouquiner non arrête
donc est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à cacher quelqu'un qu'il vient de
tuer d'un coup de couteau dans le ventre
alors
la porte il dit je les buts et chérie et
vous dites et où il est dans le coffre
mais tu dis mais qu'est ce qu'on va
faire il faut que tu m'aides à le cacher
fait quoi là dit on a calmé dans le
coffre
du nom
dans le moteur
alors je le cool je coule le cadavre à
vous mettez les pieds du cadavre dans du
béton et vous jetez le cadart par un
pont dans la seine d'accord d'accord je
peux prendre le même truc que vous
voulez est ce que j'ai l'air très bon
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête
mareva galanter à vous mettre à la
drogue bat pour eux c'est faire
la charité que le python ou encore canal
+ universal mais bien si les nouveaux
canard c'est vivendi ya plus de domicile
et dingo canada corp la drogue
imaginez un soir il arrive il vous dit
ça y est moi je me suis accroché à
l'héroïne c'est super essaye montre
tombera
il faut rien quoi je vous sais pas ce
que vous dites mais c'est pas un
horrible ça peut arriver je l' ai vu ça
déjà
c'est que 17 buts
c'est
pas des questions l'air n'a détruit que
j'invente est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à prendre 17 kg
j'en ai pris dix ans j'étais miss france
2010 est d'accord et je vois pas
pourquoi oui bah si l'asnl et rubens ou
les botero peux vous dire apprendre le
17 kg pour faire plaisir je crois
qu'après tout ça s'il me demande et tout
ça je serais plus je serai très
longtemps vous serez pris en charge non
c'est bien sûr la question clotilde
courau
d'irma la douce est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à embrasser cent fois
ses chaussettes sage
voulez mais un peu quand même est-ce que
par un mot vous seriez prête à vous
faire refaire le nez pourquoi il est pas
bon ceci dit c'est pas la question oui
mais justement
vous et lui et il aime ça des gros nez
avoir diffusé je ne veux même pas
imaginer ce que je pourrais devenir
après tout ça si vous êtes tous à 17 kg
de grosses ben oui puisque pour la
drogue et tu sais
oui
bon non mais c'est un test c'est pour
voir s'ils s'aiment est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à accepter quelque
petit tout petit pull infidélité
beau
juste le beauf
alors si on est complice pour copains
intéressant
je trouve ça dégueulasse
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
qu'il est maîtresse non je voulais même
pas hors des questions tu seulement
heureux d'avoir une maîtresse ils
peuvent être heureux d'avoir une
maîtresse il arrête moi c'est pas
possible
donc vous vivez pas trop avec la
maîtresse non vous refuseriez d'année
tous les droits dans des clubs
échangistes c'est pas la peine que je
voulais pose cette question moi je
faire des questions et vous refuser d'y
répondre voilà alors tant pis est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à devenir
son esclave sexuelle
à eva des corrections de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux